hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and as might be becoming clear
through the various topics of the
podcast one of the things I'm fascinated
by is the boundary between living and
not quite living by which I mean
artificial life artificial synthetic
intelligence robots all the different
ways in which we can build the things
that are have some lifelike qualities
but yet aren't really alive and on the
other side how living things are
manifestations of underlying physical
processes so today we're gonna be
talking to Kate autumn Allah who is an
assistant professor of genetics cell
biology and development at the
University of Minnesota and Kate is
involved in building synthetic life
building individual cells from scratch
this is something this is a field
artificial life synthetic biology that
has a bunch of successes and
controversies to its name there's
different things you can do so famously
Craig Ventnor got in the news years ago
roughly 10 years ago now for building
the first artificial organism but he
which was a tremendous accomplishment
but what really happened is he took a
pre-existing bacterial cell removed its
genome and replaced it with the genome
that he had synthesized he and his team
of course had synthesized they had
written a new DNA strand and that booted
up inside the cell and got it going but
it clearly wasn't starting from scratch
so Kate and her collaborators are among
a group of people who are trying to
literally build cells from scratch the
cell wall all the internal workings and
so forth we don't yet have a working
artificial cell that is truly alive in
the sense that it reproduces it goes its
own way but in some sense that's better
as we learn in this conversation we can
tune protocells to do things that are
useful to us without worrying about them
reproducing too much and going crazy and
taking over the world so kate is a
member of a large collaboration called
build a cell where we are working toward
this goal of actually creating a
self-sustaining cell all by itself from
purely synthetic ingredients and what we
will be able to do with that the
prospects the frontiers for the future
here are truly amazing to me it's really
we're at the very beginning of a
revolution in this kind of thing and
Kate's an extremely articulate
spokesperson for this kind of work so
this is definitely a fun mind-bending
and you know slightly provocative kind
of podcast so let's go
[Music]
Kamala
welcome to the mindscape podcast thank
you it's great to be here so you know as
someone who's done cosmology in my life
I sometimes get accused of you know
playing God thinking about the universe
all at once and so I'm very happy to be
here with someone who creates life in
their laboratory you're way closer to
playing God than I ever will be trying
we're not as good as the original God
must have been trying to get there so is
it fair to say that you know one of your
goals in the lab is to create life from
scratch from nonliving components the
definition of scratch is flexible some
people say to really start from scratch
you have to start from inorganic
molecules and guide the chemical
evolution all the way to a living system
this is not what we're doing we're
treating big time we're taking existing
very complex by organic molecules and
enzymes and trying to put them together
into it something that resembles a
living system okay so you're using the
fact that life already exists and that's
helpful and so you're gonna take
guidance why not you know like you said
God did it right the first time so you
can you can he did it right he did it
we're trying to improve on it and how
did you get into this are you you a
biologist by training no I'm actually
chemist by training okay and my approach
to it this chemical I think life is just
a complex chemistry and I would like to
be able to reconstitute it using
principles of chemical engineering and I
got into it because I always thought
it's kind of cool I mean growing up when
you watch all those science fiction
movies they always have like an
astrobiologist on a spaceship and one
day I realized this is actually a job
one can do yeah so I win don't started
doing it then thanks grain so let's
let's back up a little bit I mean if
you're making life from scratch then it
really makes you need to think about the
question of what life is what's the
definition right and you know in my book
the big picture I quoted the famous NASA
definition of life and I said I didn't
like this definition I
I don't like it either but so tell us
what it is and then why do you don't let
me so NASA definition of life is a
chemical system capable of their own yin
evolution and I don't like that
definition but it's the best one we have
the main reason why I don't like it it's
because it's not a functional
experimentally verifiable definition so
when we go out and drill under the ice
on you of Europe how we're gonna find
some organic soap NASA definition of
life is not going to help us to define
whether there is life on Europa or not
same for saying for Mars same for
Enceladus it's a great definition for
philosophers but it's not a practical
definition that we can use when we get
our hands on a sample well yeah the part
I didn't like was the Darwinian
evolution part I mean that's something
that life as we know it clearly involves
but if I made a molecule by molecule
replica of a living being except didn't
include its reproductive capacity yes to
be alive right that's that's a very good
point to like for example I'm not alive
myself because I cannot undergo their
wing and evolution myself there you go
and I've chosen not to so maybe I'm not
alive either
exactly so the problem with definitions
of life though is as soon as you come up
with one you will find an exception that
doesn't fit it we need to have a
definition is that an important thing we
need to have a working definition
because we will have samples from other
planets and they will contain organics
we know that the universe is lousy with
organics organic matter just gets formed
a biotic li what do you mean when you
say the word organics um anything that's
carbon-based anything that resembles
organic molecules known on earth we know
we can find amino acids nucleotides
lipids we're finding them spectral
spectrophotometric Li in interstellar
clouds right we know there will be
organics like that on and pretty much
any surface that can support liquid
water in the universe yeah I think that
some non scientist can get confused by
this because they think the word organic
is like organic food like it's been
placed naturally and stuff like that or
at the very least has something to do
with life but chemists think that
organic is just anything that has a
carbon atom in it yep um yeah pesticides
are organic believe it or not so yeah I
mean by organic I mean
not a biotic molecule just an organic
molecule in that organic chemistry sense
but what amazingly it was certainly
amazing to me when I learned that you
can find not just organic molecules but
several of the molecules that are very
relevant to life are literally out there
in interstellar space
there are amino acids out there yeah
there are no cloud bases out there there
are probably sugars out there and this
does not mean that there's living beings
out there that does not mean there are
living beings out there and that's the
problem with lack of a functional
definition of life because we're finding
building blocks of life so you cannot
say that if I go out to Mars and find
amino acids that means there's life on
Mars okay I mean if I go up to Mars and
find the right stereochemistry
terrestrial amino acids that just means
we contaminated Mars which we probably
did anyway by now do you think we did Oh
totally I mean haven't we tried it don't
doesn't NASA try very hard not they also
try very hard not to crush on landing
the track records not in their favor so
um we I think we contaminated Mars the
question is whether anything we dragged
out there would survive or not and also
there are probably still environments on
Mars that we managed to not contaminate
and it would be nice to keep it that way
but I don't have high hopes um we
probably also contaminated more with all
the crap we crash there but we have not
yet had a chance to contaminate neither
Europe nor Enceladus and these are the
very likely candidates for places where
there could be life in our sorry so this
is jumping ahead of it that's perfectly
okay so you think that the moons of
Jupiter and Saturn are better places
right now to look for life than Mars I
think we still should look because Mars
is the only other planet that had
conditions that closely resembled earth
before Mars lost its water and
atmosphere it was habitable by our
definition of habitable like human
definition of habitable so if there was
a probiotic evolution that could lead to
the origin of terrestrial like living
beings that could have happened on Mars
more likely on Mars really than on mark
definitely another problem though is
that Earth is spreading crap as we speak
like it's
we're always shedding atmosphere and our
atmosphere contains Spore
and we know that those can travel so if
we find the tardigrade on mars or more
likely tardigrades poor on mars that
doesn't mean tardigrades originated on
Mars independently no I mean it's
amazing to me also like space is amazing
to me you can find meteorites here on
earth that came from volcanoes on Mars
right and the planets share material
with each other galaxies planetary
systems even coal galaxies share
material with each other yeah so that I
guess that's another reason why we need
a functional definition of life because
if we find a system that resembles
something we would expect life to look
like we can't right now we don't have a
good definition to say if it actually is
alive or not but we know we'll find
stuff because stuff is being shed all
over and I guess life is just very
promiscuous huh that's spreading
everywhere and but and but is it
possible that the definition is less
important than a list of characteristics
and we can find things with some
characteristics but not others and I
think that's where the field is going
right now people are starting to agree
that we can make a experimentally
trackable list of characteristics and if
we find something that fits some of
those then we'll be really happy so what
would you go beyond your personal list
of characteristics that you would call
kind of life II I like homeostasis
because homeostasis let's get
maintaining internal environment that is
different significantly different in
composition of molecules ions pH and
whatnot to the external environment and
ability to maintain it actively so not
just be different in an environment but
actually work for it and that's
homeostasis to me and good so you're
separate from your environment and
you're somehow it's not just because
you're a locked room and there's things
inside you but you're you're interacting
with the environment in some way and yet
maintaining your difference okay to me
that's the biggest hallmark of a living
system replication is important I'm
actually a big fan of their own Ian's
evolution for the living system I mean
for a living system as a whole I don't
know of any better way to evolve the
during an evolution but and every
individual organism does not and does
not have to undergo their own evolution
sure but I think yeah the people who
want that to be the definition say well
okay but the species has to do it or
something like that right the fact that
you and I do not have children it's not
gonna stop exactly
members of our species do exactly and
that's to me that's another very
important property and then another
property that's I have a hard time
defining and I don't quite understand it
myself but I really like it is the
complexity so basically there is a
certain threshold of complexity of
molecules and their ways molecules
interact with each other that we're only
finding in living living systems on
earth and not in nonliving and that
complexity is very hard to measure but
once you measure it and you plot it
complexity versus whatever other
function of aliveness you want a name
it's a very clear boundary between life
and non-life is how complex you are
we're just we as life are just insanely
complex and we don't understand what
properties of what we are come as those
emergent properties of complex molecules
interacting with each other and to me
that is a hallmark of life but it's a
really terrible definition because it's
not very it's all vague but it's very
vague and not experimentally trackable
at this point and it's obviously I mean
it's not obviously but I will certainly
buy the idea that every example we know
life is extremely complex but you're
making another interesting point that
there's no examples of non life that are
that complex yes so that's actually a
dividing line if only we could sort of
formalize what we meant yeah and okay
but there's sort of features of life as
we know it like DNA and so forth but I
like that we're being a little bit more
general than that so we have often
people say compartmentalization but but
is that tied up with your idea of
homeostasis um to me personally yes I'm
a lipid bilayer person so I I wrote four
by layers all over the universe I would
like to find them but there are other
ways of maintaining compartmentalized
without a cell membrane
so I think compartmentalization is
necessary because you need to separate
yourself from the environment but it
doesn't necessarily have to be a cell
membrane
well good this is one of the questions
that I had coming in and we're familiar
with life as we know it of course is is
it safe to say that all life as we know
it is in the form of cells or
multicellular organisms there's some
like a virus is maybe I would not
consider viruses alive and even if you
do consider them a life they still meet
crap inside a membrane to live because
they have to impact the cell to
replicate okay but then so it's obvious
why that would be helpful right if you
want to maintain this complexity and so
forth let's seal yourself off so there's
a cell membrane around that your inner
workings and it's on the outside but you
know that's just because there's many
examples in the history of science where
scientists guessed one way and turned
out to be wrong are we really sure you
couldn't have something like life
without membranes at all oh we totally
could we need a compartment but the
compartment doesn't have to be a
membrane at all the compartment could be
peptide it could be any other polymer
and the compartment could even be a
physical containment for example and a
piece of rock with little cavities all
over and each of those cavities could
have its own distinct environment and
some people even propose things like
that as the origin of life right yeah no
but I guess when I meant membrane I was
thinking is a non biologist like any
compartment but could we even have non
compartmentalized life just life sort of
in a network that had different parts or
something but it's not impossible but
everything we know about that's another
problem everything we know about
properties of life is derived from this
sample size that equals one not stupid
because a scientist we like at least a
triplicates give me two more life forms
and I can tell you more about properties
of life right now we only have one life
form so looking at everything that life
form does we absolutely need a
compartment and that's the current going
knowledge based on all the data we have
I would say it's not impossible to
imagine a non compartmentalised life but
it would have
of problems that would have to be solved
one way or another when you say we have
an example we have one we had many
organisms but they all came from yeah
they're all seen on dirt I mean on the
pipe on the biochemical level life
terrestrial life is kind of a boring
because there's not much variety
everyone does the same kind of
metabolism everyone uses the same few
hundred molecules to does to do life to
do the basic process of life so yes we
have incredible diversity in anatomy and
physiology but on if you look at that
biochemical level everyone does DNA RNA
proteins everyone use this crappy
catalyst called the ribosome to make
proteins it's it's not that much variety
not a lot of cleverness in the
engineering and there's there's
governess for sure but there's not
enough variety I should say yeah okay so
we can generalize we cannot say life as
a general biochemical phenomena does
this or that because we just simply
don't know it because we only have one
life right now the study and that's I I
really got into the whole idea of lipid
by lipid membranes is that lipid
bilayers because they have two leaflets
so tell me what a lipid is talked about
the Hydra philia and hydrophobia and all
that stuff because it's amazing to me so
yeah if it's a really cool um so lipid
has a tail in a head lipid is molecule
yes lipid is a molecule and it has to be
classified as a lipid it has to have a
tail and a head and the head is polar
which makes it hydrophilic and that tail
is nonpolar which makes it hydrophobic
so liking water or hating water liking
water and hating water so head loves
water tail hates water
so now drop it in water what happens is
heads get all happy because there's
water around so they stick their heads
into the water
tails hate water so what are you gonna
do they're gonna snuggle other tails and
that's how a membrane is formed the
tails do not like to be around water so
the tails face each other and the heads
stick out the problem is if you have
tails facing each other they still have
the problem of the fact that there is
water at the end
of them so they solve the problem by
inviting other tails to back them up so
imagine two trucks backing up into each
other that backs of the tracks are
facing each other and the Front's of the
tracks are facing outside so the front
likes water to front like water and
stare into the water and that makes the
membrane the inside of the membrane can
hide all this hydrophobicity inside it
and it's an incredibly stable
conformation they really hate to not do
that
that's why membranes form spontaneously
when you drop lipids into water yeah the
other nice thing is they're pretty easy
to make right they just happen they just
happen exactly and that's why I'm a big
fan of lipids because we know lipid can
be synthesized by orally I'm so there
were lipids around even before there was
life around and once you have lipids
you're going to have bilayer membranes
and once you have bilayer membranes they
like to be spherical it's not another
amazing thing right yeah it's not
healthy for a membrane to be flat it
wants to be spherical is basically like
a soap bubble
I mean membranes are essentially soap
bubbles so if you make a soap bubble you
cannot make a flat open soap bubble when
you make a soap bubble it ends up being
a sphere whether you want it or not and
that's what lipid bilayers do they end
up being spheres and then once you have
that sphere you can put stuff inside and
start living yeah so these lipids very
naturally give us a way to
compartmentalize are there other ways
besides the business you can make
protein compartments and we do we as
life do you can make compartments that
are amorphous there are those awesome
proteins that are called
intrinsically disordered proteins that
can undergo face change phase change
transition depending on external
environment and we actually have them we
have those membraneless organelles in
our cytoplasm that creates this kind of
islands of different chemical
composition just because they want to
like this property of those molecules so
that's a way to compartmentalize things
you can also use completely different
kind of molecules you could imagine
sugars making some sort of a compartment
you could imagine other polymers making
some sort of a compartment or you can
imagine just rocks making a compart
and okay but most life as we know it
cells are the membranes of the cells are
made of these by layers all life as we
know it it was a slip had seen there by
layers so in the one hand it's they're
easy to make on the other hand they're
not completely watertight right like
some things can come in and out which is
important to being awesome yes and the
really good ones they're highly evolved
I mean by highly I mean bacteria and
above evolved life has pretty watertight
membranes to get anything across the
membrane you need membrane channels and
that's actually really good because then
you have control over what goes across
you're remembering because you control
your channels so in some sense the cells
like little island and there's these
bridges across the membrane so and they
have control over those bridge and is
yeah there's Border Patrol letting some
things in and out so you can see how
things are beginning to get a bit more
complicated yeah that's one of the
problems when you think about the origin
of life is a good membrane will not be
very permeable so life had to pretty
early figure out how to get stuff across
the membrane using membrane channels
membrane transporters right
okay so we have compartmentalization my
impression is in the origin of life
community among the aspects of life
compartmentalization is sort of the
easiest one to understand how it could
have gotten going is that right it's the
one that we made a lot of progress on
yeah experimentally it's it sounds easy
but experimentally these are one of the
toughest projects to run because lipids
they do form those those liposomes one
if you want them to but actually working
with them handling them is kind of a
pain in the lower box so it's i that's
that's all i've been doing through grad
school so to me it's not that incredibly
hard because I was just trained to do it
but in a great scheme of things there
are a lot of other experiments are
easier but the origins field made great
progress in making those compartments
good and then the other things we
mentioned were you know the e to be able
to replicate and you need some sort of
engine inside you need some metabolize
that's that's how I think of what life
is it has those three aspects of
compartmentalization metabolism and
replication is that is that fair am i
oversimplifying no that's definitely
fair it's definitely oversimplified but
it's also fair yeah and what what
qualifies exactly is metabolism I mean
and this is where I get into physics
right like life uses fuel it uses the
low entropy energy from its environment
one way or another I'm the worst person
to ask about it because I think of it
from the practical functional point of
view to me metabolism is taking simple
building blocks and making something
different and more complex out of it and
that ties very strongly to maintaining
homeostasis basically taking your
environment has a certain chemical
composition your guts have different
chemical composition if you want to do
life you have to take stuff from your
environment and process it so it makes
the inside of you so basically your
environment has something that doesn't
look like you and you're the reason you
have metabolism is because that
basically means you have machinery to
take something that is not you and make
it into you and that's the easiest
definition of metabolism to me at least
is that processing building blocks that
don't look like and result and making it
end result the end result being you in
this case it's fascinating to me because
this is definitely a field where there's
a lot of things have the character of we
know it when we see it
metabolism and then we're still
searching for the precise definition
absolutely and we're kind of again
hampered by the fact that we don't have
anything to compare with we only have
one we only know one way of doing
metabolism because we only know one
life-form if we had few other to know
cut we could try to generalize more and
that one way we have is the story of ATP
and things like that
we have little batteries basically
little fuel storage services inside
ourselves yep and they're all made by
one company everybody uses ATP so that
yeah kind of hard to generalize monopoly
yeah there's totally is monopoly and is
it I mean as a cosmetologist I want to
ask or
someone who has been involved in debates
on the fine-tuning of the universe is it
or would it ever be clear that this is
simply the best way to do it rather than
just some accident of history that
chemistry happened to make use of um it
would be clear once we find a completely
independent life-forms if we find let's
say 27 different life forms all over the
universe and they all use ATP then
there's definitely something about ATP
but I don't think there is anything
special about ATP I think it just
happened to be around and we started
using it okay that's good so the other
special thing then is on the replication
side we use DNA right DNA and RNA both
both involved and then like you said the
ribosome tells the RNA or actually takes
the RNA in and make the protein yes is
that a fair way to say it right and this
also seems very specific I know friends
of mine who what they do for living is
they build little computers and robots
out of DNA and my first guess was that
that was because DNA's all over the
place we know about it from being living
beings but it was explained to me that
you know forget about living beings DNA
is a really good information storage
mechanism it is it's a great information
storage mechanism but it's definitely
not the only one you can imagine and
there are two parts to DNA one is the
backbone which is what gives it
stability and flexibility and that I
think might be one of the more common
ways of doing it if I were to bet how
those 27 random life-forms all over the
universe would look like I would not be
surprised for them to have something
that resembles the backbone of our DNA
but then the information is actually
stored in new cloud bases those for DNA
no claw bases and these I think are
relatively random because you can
imagine different kinds of nucleobases
that could easily do the same thing
right and there's this weird thing that
there are four different nucleolus and
they appear in groups of 3 so 4 times 4
times 4 is 64 right so 64 different
possibilities and we use all of them but
in kind of a redundant coding scheme
right there's the only sort of 20 of the
cat
worries that we actually make use of is
that right 21 yeah 21 okay stop
oh yeah there's one that the period at
the end of the sentence you need that
right okay and so you're not sure or
you're suspecting that these this choice
of four nucleobases could have been very
very different if you ran if you tell me
you can run a probiotic evolution on
earth over and over again ten times I
would say all of those ten times we
would end up with an information storage
polymer that would have slightly
different nuclear bases there's many
different types of nuclear bases that
could work
chemically to do is that something that
synthetic life researchers are looking
into like could they improve on DNA it
wouldn't necessarily be improving you I
think most of the other choices wouldn't
actually improve DNA is great because
it's just stable enough yeah it base per
stably enough to be solid when you need
it but then when you need to unwind it
it doesn't hold on for dear life it
actually is willing to let go and people
have built experimental systems that use
different nuclear bases and it works
okay that's good to know I'm slightly
more radical question is DNA is sorta or
something DNA like the idea of a chain
of bases or molecules that that store
information in a one-dimensional chain
it sounds pretty robust the only way I
could think could generalize that would
be what about like a two-dimensional
sheet could we imagine a genetic
information being stored in some sort of
two-dimensional pattern and could that
be more complicated or efficient but
just hard to get off the ground and
early life ah this would probably work
but then your cells would have to be
ginormous you're a synthetic biologist
you can make that happen
physical chemical limitations on the
size of a cell like if you have too much
surface you're spending too much time
walking on that surface and that's your
problem so they're basic laws of physics
chemistry etc in the environment we have
but it may be in very different
environments conditions look very
differences okay good to know
well mark it down that we talked about
that here if we discover it on Europa or
something like that you know for example
if it's a rock
life you could imagine two-dimensional
system you could imagine or other
chemistry happening in the
two-dimensional okay all right so that's
pancake life yes mmm pancakes so we had
those basic ingredients I mean I think
that it's be it behooves us as
scientists to try to think beyond these
obvious things cuz like you say where
our imaginations are poisoned by the
fact that we had this one example but
but it does also seem pretty sensible
that compartmentalisation metabolism and
replication will be essentially
Universal in life so how close have we
come to making that ourselves to to
being engineers as well as chemists and
biologists that depends who you ask what
have we done we put it that way the
other way around I think there's a lot
of sort of waste of time arguing over
who made an artificial life like we've
heard news reports and things like that
but let's put it this way what have we
done what steps have we take made along
the way we've made the biggest progress
on compartmentalization we can recreate
artificially compartments that looked
like living compartments we can make
pretty good metabolism inside them so we
can put together molecules that make
proteins that uptake nutrients from the
environment we suck at replication still
that haven't that problem have not been
solved we are unable to recreate a
autonomous spontaneous replication
system we can replicate those
compartments by hand like we can force
them to replicate but we cannot design
them in a way that they will be willing
to replicate out of their own desire
like out as a result of the biochemical
processes happening inside them we made
ok progress on homeostasis we can make
those little synthetic cell compartments
that actively maintain their composition
that is different than the composition
of the outside they're not as robust and
they're nowhere nearly as robust as
living systems but the danger kind of
blame attempts at recreating living
systems so they won't be as robust and I
do have this recollection that they've
been experiments where you tried to make
either RNA or the equivalent of RNA that
would reproduce itself
we don't yet have an example of
synthetic single molecules that
reproduce themselves right and this is
always I should have mentioned this
earlier but of course when we say
reproduction things like fire reproduce
themselves or crystals reproduce
themselves but now we're talking about
reproduction with information stored
it's just the crucial thing that's why
RNA is so good right RNA and DNA and all
the other an ace yeah okay okay we did I
explained to us what we've heard in the
news there was several years ago we
heard the craig Venter made artificial
life but you know it all depends on what
you mean so forget about whether he made
artificial life or not what did he do he
took a bacteria called mycoplasma which
is the smallest known independently
living cell they're parasites but they
live outside of cells so they took that
cell they took the genome of that cell
and they bombarded it with pieces of DNA
that randomly insert random DNA
sequences all over the genome that
called transposon insertion so basically
you for cells to uptake DNA and put it
to wherever in their genome now what
happens is if you put this random piece
of DNA and you are in your genome you
can be lucky and put it somewhere where
it's not gonna kill you or you can put
it inside a gene that you absolutely
have to have to live and then you just
end up dead yeah so that's what they did
and then they grew whole bunch of those
mutant bacteria they sequenced it all
and they found that there is a lot of
genes that you can shut off that you can
insert those random pieces of DNA into
and the cell survives it might not be as
healthy might not might not be as happy
might not divide as quickly but it will
be alive and so that way they figure out
which genes are absolutely essential for
survival and which are not and they
removed all of those genes that were not
essential for survival and they came up
with this minimal genome so that was the
first step
they actually minimized an already
smallest living organism now then the
next thing is they actually synthesize
that whole genome chemically that sounds
easy right now in the age of twenty nine
and other high throughput DNA synthesis
but back then where they were doing it
ten years ago that was a huge deal to
actually synthesize the entire genome of
a living organism and I did it then how
do you make it to be actually alive is
you take that synthetic genome that DNA
that was synthesized on a machine and
never have never been alive and you put
it inside a cytoplasm of another living
cell they pick the cell that was very
closely related to what they started
with
they put they picked another species of
a mycoplasma a slightly bigger and just
just slightly more complex and they
developed this procedure called genome
transplantation where they take the
synthetic DNA put it inside a living
cell and that synthetic DNA takes over
the natural DNA that came with that
living cell to begin with so you didn't
remove the original DNA just superseded
it
yes used and that's why I think I mean
this was probably one of the biggest
achievements of synthetic biology and
biotechnology to date but it is not
making life because you always had life
cell that genome transplantation was
replacing genome of one organism with a
genome of another so there was always
life there
it was never dead and then not dead but
years old so they took the artificial
genome put it inside another cell and
that cell started expressing proteins of
that from that artificial genome and
started slowly changing morphing into
that new organism and that's how the new
organism was born and that's how the sin
cells were born sin as of synthetic
cells so certainly pretty good what they
did oh they're amazing it was the
technological advancements that we get
out of those products are incredible
most common way everyone uses these days
to do molecular cloning is a technique
that was born during this project
because they needed it and there was
being available so they made it and also
the do you know transplantation
technique didn't exist before they
started working on it
and there are several iterations of that
since L um they made it smaller and then
yet smaller and then yet smaller and
then they made slightly bigger because
it started growing too small too slow
for anyone to be able to put up with it
but there is many of those organisms
right now where we know every single
gene and we can control basically what
every one of those genes do it might be
worth you know just thinking about the
actual process of this because I think
people have in mind you know going in
there with tweezers and a scalpel and
and cutting and re pasting DNA very tiny
tweezers but that's not what we actually
do know what do we do what we do is we
cut the DNA to leave ends that have
specific sequence and then we bring in
new DNA with ends that have a sequence
that matches those cut points and then
we ligate it we glue it back together
which really just means let the
chemistry happen that brings it back
together yes we are never picking up one
strand and another strand and with our
hands putting it not quite nobody has
hands that small yeah their molecules I
mean there's nothing that we can make
that is that small and also when we say
synthesizing a genome because I myself
am not completely clear on this is it
like we literally have the complete list
GC TT a and we could type in any list we
want and make a DNA molecule like that
that's how we're making DNA these days
as there are those machines that take so
there are four no claw bases and you can
program a machine to Kapil to connect
those nuclear bases in a very specific
order and it doesn't take forever to do
that I mean these are long right these
are millions of so far the synthetic
genome they actually had to develop
several techniques to to do it to stitch
it together most of the time what we do
like on a daily basis is we're making
jeans that are few hundred to couple
thousand no claw bases long and that
doesn't take very long but that wouldn't
be enough to power all bacteria
absolutely not I mean the the smallest
nann genome is 474 genes and that's
quite a bit of DNA yeah so how many
bases in a gene I know that's wildly
different numbers but um it's very
wildly different
it's from few hundred to a few thousand
right so if the state-of-the-art then at
that time you know a few years ago was
sort of redesigning the DNA and then
plugging it back into an existing
bacterium how far we come since then
we've come really far in understanding
how this organism works but we're still
unable to take a genome plug it into a
nonliving system and to get life out of
it yeah okay that's what my lab is
trying to do as you're trying to do with
collaboration with the craig Venter
Institute people we're trying to
basically do what they did accept our
jassi's is not alive so when they took
that artificial DNA put it in a living
cell and that living cell changed into
the new cell what we're trying to do so
far unsuccessfully but we're hopefully
getting there is we're trying to take
the nonliving piece of DNA and mix it
with nonliving components that make
proteins that make membranes and see if
the system can can write itself up can
start making all the proteins that will
organize in a proper way in which we
expect life to organize and that would
really be well I don't know we I already
said we should know about the
definitions but it sounds like that
would really be a synthetic life-form
that would be a life-form that was
created from nonliving components the
the reason I'm hesitant to say synthetic
to me personally it would be synthetic
but there are many people that would
consider a synthetic life-form only
something that is completely different
from an existing architecture so what
we're making is still DNA RNA 21 amino
acids perfect same we're trying to make
a copy of a little of a living cell
basically from nonliving components
if you want to talk about artificial in
the proper sense of the world it would
be something that designed to be
different than a what you're using as a
template okay what's the kind this is
why I don't care about the definitions
because both of those are interesting
but they are different so we'll yeah
we'll count them as both interesting one
of the is it true one of the obstacles
here is that even in the tiniest genomes
for these little bacteria we don't know
exactly what all those genes do right
like Ventnor was able to knock out some
and not kill it but there's others that
if you knock them out the bacteria won't
bacteria rise anymore but we don't know
why
absolutely and they're called essential
genes of a known function and they're
the biggest headache that we as a field
have right now we know those genes are
absolutely necessary but we've got no
idea what they do and that's kind of
frustrating so even when we're you know
typing in our keyboard GT TAC whatever
we know that certain sequences are
necessary but it's not as if we can say
I'm typing this because this is going to
do the following thing in the bacterium
right that's so frustrating about life
in general it's a black box yeah are we
is that an ongoing research thing we're
trying to figure that out
yes is there some dream at some point of
being able to type in a genome sequence
and just send a simulate on the computer
what it will do it would be amazing and
people are working towards it but it's
impossible right now because we don't
know what all the proteins are actually
doing and is it just because things are
too complicated is that the obstacle
yeah okay
so one of the things you're trying to do
is not only make a synthetic living
breathe not breathing but living cell
but also you know things that are cell
like that might not quite rise to the
level of being alive yes and so what
what I was good at that actually we can
make things that are not alive but are
quite complex so for instance what I
mean what what do they do you know what
stops them from being alive complexity
mostly um none of our systems
self-replicate right now so we can
replicate it but it doesn't self
replicate it's a crucial distinction so
it looks like a cell looks like a cell
is do you like a cell but is not a set
okay but it does that DNA it does have
DNA it does have RNA in desk of ribosome
so makes protein makes proteins well
duplicate itself they want replicating
itself you can go in there you can clone
it yes okay and what is the usefulness
of these things we can study processes
that we cannot study in a complex life
cell because the complex because the lot
natural life cells are still black boxes
no matter how much we simplify it we
just have no idea what's going on in
there we can study single pathway and
hope we cut everything that interacts
with that pathway but we most likely
didn't in our system it's engineer able
from the first principles like from the
every single building block can be
manipulated so if we want to for example
reconstitute a signaling pathway or it
reconstitute a oncogenic pathway or make
a gene circuit that produces certain
molecule we can design it from scratch
we can build it and we know it's exactly
what we were hoping it will be because
there is no endogenous metabolism that
will mess with our experiments and is
this potentially useful just for you
know down-to-earth
crass Commerce kind of reasons you know
for engineering and medicine and things
like that beyond the fundamental
questions of life and time very much so
that's a lot of what is paying the bills
right now is when you think about bio
manufacturing a lot of progress has been
made in making pathways that can make
anything you want and we need those
pathways because maybe a little bit of
off topic but we need to ramp up our bio
engineering bio manufacturing
capabilities because we're running out
of crude sources of chemicals like when
people freak out about running out of
oil they freak out for energy reasons
but we we have different ways of getting
energy we can have solar we can have
wind we can have atomic we do not have
right now a good replacement for all the
petrochemicals so all the crap we get
from oil that builds everything around
us we don't have a replacement source
for that so we need to learn how to do
it with the only good renewable
biochemical chemical factories we can
think of that will always be sustainable
which is biomass
during processes so we can have
biological processes that make all the
molecules we need their problem is that
cells kind of don't like doing it
because a lot of those molecules are
toxic to begin with huh so we can build
pathways that make the molecules we want
but then we introduce them to cells to
natural cells they look at it and know
part of it they say I'm not going to do
it because it's toxic to me and that's
the biggest problem in bio manufacturing
right now is how do you make all those
complex toxic molecules now a nice thing
about synthetic cells is that they're
not alive so they don't care so you can
build a synthetic cell that makes
something incredibly toxic or hard to
make and it will not kill it because you
can't kill something that's already dead
another thing is we're kind of slowly
entering this area of talk of
personalized medicine where we want to
make drugs in small quantities tailored
to the needs of every particular patient
and if you think about chemical
processes for making complex biomolecule
biomolecules that can be drugs setting
up a process for each molecule takes
forever and it's really hard if you
could have a platform that very
versatile easily programmable to make
small amounts of biomolecules that can
be used as medicine or nutrients on
demand when you need it where you need
it and not more and no less that would
be really useful and that's another area
where artificially engineered organisms
could be really useful
yeah there's no such thing as off topic
so don't worry about that we should talk
about this because I like that you
brought up the petrochemical thing
because that always struck me when
people worried about you know fossil
fuels and stuff like that running out of
oil for gasoline basically and I'm
always thought like we do a lot of
things with oil other than gasoline and
these are this is a finite resource and
we are literally setting it on fire
right we're literally burning it but so
you're saying is that maybe your little
semi living synthetic cells can help us
reconstitute the sort of chemistry that
we might get out of the ground for free
I mean we have to find a way of doing it
because I'm maybe I'm a little too
optimistic but I think by the time we
run out of oil we will have
enough renewable energy sources that we
can drive our cars and run away is your
heat but we still don't have a good path
to replacing all the chemicals and
that's something I feel like doesn't get
enough attention because everyone just
freaks out about energy and not about
everything else we get from oil well and
it it opens up a whole set of vistas
that I've heard people sort of mentioned
in passing about for example combating
climate change or something like that by
designing little microorganisms to go
chew up the co2 and other things in the
atmosphere that we don't want the
greenhouse gases is that at all feasible
in your mind um this is not the area
that I'm an expert in I would love to
see that happen I'm a little afraid of
thinking about that because we've seen
how well it goes when we try to release
an organism into environment that that's
what could go wrong exactly so doing
that on a planetary scale kind of gives
me creeps but that doesn't mean it's not
doable I also think there are a lot of
problems with climate change that could
be solved without those giant planetary
scale interventions it's by no means the
replacement for doing more sensible
things about fixing climate change but
but the medicine stuff I think is is
also extremely promising I just get the
impression that a hundred years from now
everyone's body will be filled with
these little designed organisms that are
keeping them healthy all the time I hope
so I bet my money on that I actually
have a little startup that's betting
money on it so we're hoping to get to
make yes I absolutely do so that's a
disclaimer I'm I'm very optimistic read
it said self-serving optimism um we are
basically trying to program those little
cells to go in and act as natural kind
of analogues to the immune system
without all the problems that the
natural immune cells have as in
self-replication ability to turn on your
own cells and fighting allergies and
things like that we maybe even combating
cancer I don't know yeah we're looking
more at that
certain allergies at this point I would
love to fight allergies as well
especially living in Minnesota in the
summer it would be awesome but we're
mostly looking at things that are very
deadly and very variable as in cancer
cos you know there's no such diseases
cancer every single cancer is slightly
different and we make those cancer drugs
that just go in and kill everything and
this then not this is probably not the
best or most efficient way of targeting
at least some of those but it's what we
have so it's a perfect target for
personalized medicine in that way and so
being able to design things another kind
of a medical medically related problem
is we hopefully are going to start
sending people back in space for longer
period longer periods of time again and
FedEx doesn't deliver to Mars yet so if
if you need specific medicine once
you're halfway through your five-year
mission to Mars you're not going to know
what you will need a few years in
advance like you're so you're gonna send
those astronauts you're gonna be as
healthy as possible but everybody can
get sick at anytime with anything and if
you're in the middle of your mission to
Mars and you suddenly get sick you need
a way to get a drug that is targeted to
your needs without knowing in advance
what your needs will be and that's one
area where kind of a design about
engineer about cells like synthetic
cells might be really useful because
they can be made to order they can be
made from scratch from a set list of
building blocks so you can imagine a
building blocks that are defined in
advance but the way you combine them
decides what the outcome is going to be
and so when halfway to your mission to
Mars you become deadly allergic to Mars
dust you make one kind of drug if you
develop a cancer in the middle of that
mission you develop another kind of drug
if your crew mate develops another kind
of cancer you make yet another drug and
so on so is that in this vision are you
not actually implanting the synthetic
cells into the patient you're just using
these synthetic cells to make some
matters
yes okay because clearly we don't
understand a lot about the interplay
between our own microbiomes and
ourselves right so introducing new cells
and to people might be risky I don't
know that's that's one of the reasons
why all the commercial applications
right now are focusing on things like
cancer because the risk to benefit ratio
is there is more risk acceptable when a
disease is almost certain to kill you
that's why we probably won't be treating
allergies with experimental therapies
but we will be treating one some of the
most deadly cancers with experimental
therapies because we don't have all that
much to lose I mean the patient who has
six months left to live live if you
extend that lifespan by another six
months you I don't want to say you won
but you have done something good that's
something good but I've heard that
you're allergic to cats so that's that's
a pretty big disaster here mindscape
we're pretty we're very Pro cast but I'm
pro dog personally and I'm not allergic
to dogs so all right it's not really the
same thing but that's okay well it will
let you struggle through your life with
that handicap so but the other thing
that strikes me as I read about this
stuff is the blurry line between
medicine and biological things and just
nanoscience just you know all the things
you might want to do at a very small
scale so robots computers engineering
this is all kinds of things you can do
with your synthetic cells we're working
on by a computing right now so we're
trying to make genetic circuits that
perform computation and store memory and
again that that's where synthetic cells
are kind of handy because people have
done a lot of good by a computing
experiment in life cells but as soon as
you take your eyes off those cells they
will start going on their own and
expressing genes they want not the genes
you want them to express Darwin man I
know since synthetic cells are dumb
enough but they don't think they can get
away with anything once you program them
to do something they will be doing that
until they run out of energy in it which
point they will just sit and stare at
the wall and not do anything else yeah
that's so that's part of the fact that
they are not alive right so there you
have some of the good benefit
of living creatures for for our
engineering purposes without the
drawback yes and are there particular
kinds of computations that it might be
useful to do this way all right now
we're still baby stepping it we're doing
boolean logic gates so the very simple
logic gates that people know from
playing with doing informatics
quote-unquote on paper so like end gate
or or gate yeah start somewhere fills an
ethicist you next and is there and I'm
just making this up is not something
I've read but is there some future hope
of making more large-scale macroscopic
materials constituted from synthetic
cells I always in my mind compare and
contrast you know skeletons and bones
which have the ability to be rigid but
you can break them and they will fix
themselves - you know robotic metallic
things which once they break that's it
is there a hope of making materials that
are you know stiff and and sturdy but
self repairing absolutely um that's one
of the probably most exciting premises
of this field is that you can imagine
programming semi living or sorta living
organisms so that they exhibit certain
properties but also keep some of those
biggest how much so biology like ability
to self repair and grow I think we need
a word for this semi living state where
it doesn't replicate it's not sort of on
its own it needs some help
but semi living well you know it's a
little creepy but that's okay I think
that sort of if you if you have a new
word you know have to go back to the
Greek roots or something like that you
can definitely coin a term there yeah
it's a brave new world I mean it's it's
how do you see what where it will be
fifty or hundred years from now and what
we're doing with synthetic cells
hopefully in a hundred years there
boundary because right now there is a
pretty clear boundary between people
like me who do this molecular biological
engineering and working nonliving
systems and people that do the classical
bioengineering with live cells hopefully
once we get better at that boundary will
disappear and we will be able to program
living or
like we program machines right now to do
the things we want and my goal is to
erase that distinction between synthetic
cells and natural cells my goal is to
build synthetic cells that are
programmable understandable definable
but behave like natural cells and as far
as robust as natural cells yeah you're
part of this build a cell collaboration
when I first heard build a cell I was
hoping it was a an app I could download
from my iPhone and I could build a cell
but we're not quite there this actually
is a game where you can put together
life organism we're not related to that
right it's the first hit when you google
our our collaboration so what is build
the cell in yet it's an international
collaboration that's supposed to bring
together people that work on building
cells and science we have no definition
of synthetic cell we have no definition
of life and everyone is motivated by
slightly different goals we would like
to unify the community around this idea
that biology is engineer able and
biology fundamental you should be
engineer able so anyone who's trying to
engineer living systems from nonliving
components or engineer living systems so
there as money so we have the ability to
manipulate them that as good as ability
to manipulate electronic or nonliving
machines all of those people are welcome
in a build a cell community
we're basically people that can come
together and talk about making life from
scratch and nobody makes fun of us it
remind me a little bit of large-scale
particle physics experiments like when
you build a detector at the Large Hadron
Collider there's a thousand people in
the collaboration and one of them builds
a little calorimeter and the other
slaughters wires together and so you
have subgroups that are interested in
the lipid bilayers others are interested
in ribosomes and so forth and you're all
working together yes it's too big of a
project for any single lab or even a
single country to tackle it so that's
why we started self-organizing into this
international community are you gonna
reach the particle physics scale where
there are thousands of authors on every
paper but not you out there yet we're
not there yet we're not quite there yet
okay so that's I think the final topic
let's go back to outer space
you know we had outer space in mind at
the beginning we're looking for life
elsewhere i I think that maybe some of
the listeners don't necessarily know
about the different environments where
we can look for life because part of
your your goal is to understand what to
look for when we're looking for life and
part of that is where we should look so
even right here in the solar system
we've had this somewhat recent change of
mind that moons of big planets are just
as good a place to look for life as
planets if not better so why would they
be better because they're smaller than
the club they can hold on to water
they're not as hot they actually have a
surface we like surface like why why
does Europa Y historically was here opa
better at holding on to water than Mars
that I actually don't know I know why
Mars lost water
why did Marsten's water because it never
developed plate tectonics
if you develop plate tectonics you can
recirculate your water you can have
water vapor in the atmosphere that gets
spit out of the volcanoes and it comes
back at as rain and gets spit out again
Mars never developed plate tectonics so
my understand I'm not good I'm not a
planetary geologist but my understanding
is the reason Mars lost water and
atmosphere is because it was passive it
that planet was passive it never
developed plate tectonics Europe eyes
frozen and it was always frozen as far
as we know so that might help because if
all your water is in a frog its
encrusted in this frozen layer of ice
it's much easier to hold on to it
it's frozen at the surface with the ice
for that and beneath that there's huge
amounts of liquid water on Europa yes
and that's why it's promising because
it's water that kind of stays there it's
encapsulated in that crust of ice and
it's doing its water stuff it's clearly
warm enough to be liquid so it's doing
stuff and that's why we have hope
there's chemistry going on in an aqueous
solution yeah there's Yassa I mean if
you have a quest Ellucian you will have
organic chemistry going on in there and
so one of your things is studying
synthetic life because we want to be
better at knowing alien life when we see
it try to mean what what should we be
looking for when we go
when we do go visit and contaminate your
oppa I I think we I can tell you very
easily what should we not be looking for
I'm still not sure what should we be
looking for I would definitely look for
organic molecules that are very complex
and coma chiral so chirality is this
orientation of which in which direction
molecules point basically and on earth
we're extremely particular about our
chirality all peptides have certain
chirality all nucleic acids have certain
chirality with no exceptions there this
is left handedness versus brightness in
molecules yeah yep and that is not
natural that natural as in a biotic you
cannot get such conserved comma
chirality at least we don't know non
living catalysts that would give you
that much specific system-wide coma
chirality so that's one thing I would
look for personally is if you find a
biochemistry and at that set of
molecules that are very complex and all
have conserved the same chirality then
that might be one of the good clues that
the process that gave rise to them is
somewhat biological but the only way to
do that is to go and scoop up the
molecules you can't do it
spectroscopically by looking at light
reflected because the light reflects the
same from left-handed and right-handed
molecules you need to go scoop it up
analyze it we're hoping to do that we're
hoping we're I think within our
lifetimes we'll get to do that it would
be easier on Enceladus because until
this is nice enough to spit it out into
the space for us they have those giant
plumes that spit out water vapors and
that water way papers probably loves you
with organics so we can just do a
flyover and I'm saying dressed it's just
yeah just place a turn if I over to pick
up a sample sounds easier to me than
land the drill pick up a sample sure
have we ever done that have you ever
done flybys the kind of scooped up
chemist chemicals and tests that I know
okay
because slowing down is always hard it's
much easier to zoom by a planet
you have to slow down slow down getting
to our baby pool with you is hard right
yeah okay it doesn't even have to be
simple return you know usually don't
actually have to bring enough fuel to
get off the planet or moon but even get
there and get close enough is hard
enough is there some feeling I've heard
it mentioned the idea that if you just
find chemistry where there's a lot of
really heavy molecules right a lot of
really long complicated molecules the
only way we know how to make them is by
a life where or biotic processes um I
would not subscribe to that because
there are many ways to polymerize to
make longer molecules from shorter
molecules and there are many ways of
doing that in D and in an abiotic way
with no life okay so this is a
controversial point different people
have different visions about yes okay
that's why it's hard
and what about far away you know if we
if we look at exoplanets we discovered
bushels full of exoplanets now we can't
go do chemical analysis of them on any
short timescale our the way is just
looking at the light we're getting from
these other planets to say oh it looks
like there might be life there so we're
not as good as looking at exoplanets as
people seem to think most of the way the
way we discover most of our exoplanet is
we're looking at the star and that
starts doing something funky so we start
doing the math and the only way that
make sense is that okay there's a planet
in the orbit we don't actually see many
we haven't seen many exit planets yet
right we see the star wobble or get a
cliff or something like that and then
that's how we actually we have seen some
exoplanets as in we've seen some of a
third light reflected from that it was a
planet which is incredibly hard or we've
seen the plugger star eclipsed by the
planet that passes right in front of it
but it's not like we can actually look
directly at the planet and take a
spectra of it so it will be very hard to
do remote life sensing like that okay
but let's say that astronomers get good
at it
is there something to look for um I
think the easiest way to do it is to
look for a physical chemical
on those planets because right now when
we discover planets we have estimated
orbits that are so large in the radius
that it can go anywhere from no liquid
water at all because it's too hot to
completely dead frozen on the other end
and we were still not sure even where
the planet lies within that orbit if we
are if we get better at defining what
physical chemical conditions we need for
life I'm so building different kinds of
artificial life under different
conditions in the lab to decide ok this
is absolutely needed for life or this is
not absolutely necessary for life then
we have those boundary conditions and
then we can look at the eggs or planets
and see ok this planet probably is
likely to have the conditions that we
know can support life and then judging
by the history of Earth life happens
quickly as soon as Earth was habitable
life came to earth so again it's sample
size that equals 1 but from that sample
we can tell that life is almost
inevitable under certain physical and
chemical conditions of a planet well I
was going to ask you about this good I
think there's some disagreement or at
least not everyone thinks that they know
the answer but they're not down sir and
that no one actually knows the answer
right but people have convictions
nevertheless is making life easy or hard
so like you say we have one data point
and in some sense the data point says it
was easy here on earth it happened
relatively quickly I mean it might have
taken almost a billion years but like
you say as soon as it became habitable
the very very early Earth was just
inhabitable and so there's no life then
but as soon as it cooled down and up
boom there was life and so maybe that
means that once you get complex
chemistry and it cools down you get life
but on the other hand we have the other
planets that don't obviously have life
on them so aren't those more data points
in some sense so right now we don't have
any other planet that currently
habitable to terrorists your life to
earth type life not even the very
particular kind but any life that would
look like
still life so that goes back to some of
the problems we discussed before it's
possible that some of the planets in the
solar system were habitable in the past
like Mars it's possible that Venus could
be habitable right now - somewhat
different life form very different I
would think a different issue
like those some there are people that
have very good arguments for the fact
that those clouds we see on Venus could
actually be made of living organisms
except we're not going to know that
unless we actually go there and test it
so we cannot say right now if we have
any other life in the solar system or
not we cannot say either way because we
haven't been there and tested that fair
enough there is no other planet that
would resemble earth in physical
chemically on in the solar system that
would have liquid water within the
correct range of temperatures and with
the magnetosphere to block the radiation
so if we if there was planet like that
and it was sterile then that would be a
very good argument for the fact that
Eris was in some way unique and we got
lucky but we just don't know we have no
idea and so since it's the end of the
podcast now we can let our hair down and
speculate a little bit everyone you know
once we get this far we have to ask
about intelligent life out there in the
universe life happened very quickly on
earth but took a long time for it to
become multicellular do you think so
what do you think our if any the
roadblocks to life becoming big and
complex it's very unlikely for that to
happen because it's the cost of becoming
complex is very high and life on Earth
only became complex when it had no other
way when there were those giant
evolutionary bottlenecks and life just
had to find a way to survive and
intelligence isn't necessarily that good
of a thing like we could sterilize earth
right now if we get into some big atomic
conflicts and it has its drawbacks it
has the intelligence has a drawbacks so
I think it's possible to imagine there
would be complex multicellular life
somewhere in the universe but the
probability of it developing at a shaken
sea of any sort is rather low okay so I
mean there's getting nuclei or I just
how you a nucleus or to go to
eukaryotes and then become multicellular
that's just what we know from the
terrestrial life right when we think
multicellular organisms have to be
eukaryotic as in heaven nucleus but that
we don't know that but do you think that
getting a sell you nucleus was a hard
step or an easy one I think that's what
I was actually an easy one that's an
easy one okay kind of pointless until
you build up on it and you do more but I
could easily imagine a multicellular
organism that's made of cells that look
like prokaryotes that don't have no
clothes all of these steps it's always a
competition right because when you
become more complex you need more
resources you need more specific
conditions but there's some benefit for
it and so it's always very unclear other
than the fact that happened in our
evolutionary history which one of these
was always going to happen in which one
of these really got like absolutely and
so so your guess is that the leap -
multicellularity might be hard in the
leap - smartness intelligence I mean
once you're multicellular part of me
thinks that some of those cells are
going to differentiate into neurons and
then it's just a matter of time I don't
know it's it might be just a matter of
time if you think about developing a
smartness of a dog or a dolphin so you
don't think that once you're as smart as
a dolphin you'll be building spaceships
I mean ventually dolphins haven't built
many yet so they don't have opposable
thumbs exactly so there are just so many
things that have to come together for a
civilization you have to be able to make
fire or have some kind of a way of
processing raw materials you have to
have four possible times more likely
like I think dogs would rule the world
if they had opposable thumbs fortunately
for us they don't and the lifespan of a
civilization at least given all we know
right now is probably not that long in
the grand scheme of things so even if
there was ever another intelligent
civilization the likelihood of them
running into a source is rather low my
personal guess is that thousands of
years from now when we're visiting all
these different solar systems in the
galaxy that will probably find cellular
life all over the place but I I'm more
skeptical about biospheres
ruled by dolphins and dogs that are that
are smart and sociable but don't have
technological capabilities but we'll see
I don't know this is this is this is a
field where there's so little data that
we it's a good reminder of how much
we're just beginning to ask some of
these questions in a principled
scientific way yeah and we will have no
way of knowing until we actually go out
there and look well hopefully your
synthetic cells will help us live
forever so that will increase the
chances that we'll be here to find out
the answer you would think so we'll be
kind of boring I think yeah bye forever
I mean just a few thousand years don't
go crazy a few thousand years be fine
alright so I'll let you get back to work
on that Kate Amidala thanks so much for
being on the podcast thank you so much
thanks for having me
[Music]